...
-Ce matin, nous avons
rendez-vous avec Julie Ferrier..
..devant ce grand théâtre parisien.
Julie voit sa grand-mère, qui a été
comédienne, une véritable passion.
Quand on lui a proposé..
..cette pièce,
où joue plusieurs générations..
..d'actrices, elle n'a pas dit non.
-En murmurant les yeux mis-clos,
..je te fais
un plan basique instinct.
-Autour de Julie,
des comédiennes de tous les âges,
..de Françoise Fabian à
Alexandra Lamy. L'intrigue parle..
..des rapports compliqués
des femmes entres elles,
..et notamment des grands-mères
avec leurs petites-filles.
Julie est une enfant de la balle.
Elle a voulu faire
le même métier que sa grand-mère.
Pour lui rendre hommage,
elle porte même son nom.
-Je suis hyper fière..
..de porter son nom...
Carrément.
Oui, oui. Je suis fière.
Si elle était là,
je pourrais avoir pas mal le trac.
J'aimerais être bien
à la hauteur.
-Ce soir, Julie ne jouera pas
devant sa grand-mère,
..car celle qu'elle a appelée
Manbelle a disparu il y a 12 ans.
Mais Manbelle gardera toujours une
place dans son coeur. Pour Julie,
..les grands-mères
ont un rôle essentiel.
-Elles détiennent la vérité, elles
ont vécu, elles ont tant de choses..
..qu'on n'a pas.
Elles savent tellement... Donc...
Je leur dirai de continuer..
..à partager avec leurs enfants
et leurs petits-enfants.
La vie, quoi...
Je pense que Manbelle, si elle s'est
aussi longtemps accrochée à la vie,
..c'était aussi
pour partager avec nous.
-Le partage et l'amour...
-Qui veut des bisous ?
-MOI !!!
-Les grands-mères
n'ont jamais été aussi..
..importantes.
Elles transmettent..
..des bonnes valeurs
entres les générations.
-Peut-être qu'on prendrait moins
de temps et on ne serait pas..
..comme on est maintenant.
Heureusement qu'elle est là.
-Parmi ces nouvelles héroïnes,
vous découvrirez Mamika et Martine.
Deux grands-mères qui partagent..
..leurs passions artistiques
avec leurs petits-enfants.
-Je suis fière d'elle.
Merci.
-Nous rencontrerons aussi
Jeanne, prête à tout..
..pour le bonheur..
..de sa grande tribu.
-Je suis contente.
Ah, il m'a entendue.
Mais oui...
-Enfin, vous suivrez Monique, une
mamie au grand coeur qui accueille..
..Eric,
..un petit Congolais
venu se faire opérer du coeur.
-Tu me fais un bisou ?
-On essaie..
..de s'occuper
nos petits-enfants.
-Qui sont ces femmes qui assument
leurs rôles de grands-mères ?
Comment sont-elles perçues ?
-Moi, c'est ma force, ça fait
partie de moi entièrement.
-Quel est le secret
de ces mamies extraordinaires ?
Plongez dans le monde
de celles qui n'ont..
..jamais été aussi modernes et
utiles à leurs petits-enfants.
-Je vais ça dans mon jardin.
-Ce matin,
Julie Ferrier nous fait visiter..
..la maison
de sa grand-mère adorée.
C'est dans ce pavillon
de banlieue..
..parisienne que..
..Manbelle a passé..
..les 20 dernières années
de sa vie.
Pour accueillir Julie,
son oncle Laurent,
..le fils de Manbelle.
Il habite cette maison..
..depuis une dizaine d'année.
Pour Julie,
..chaque pièce est associée
à des moments partagés avec elle.
-Je me vois à 4 ans
avec Manbelle...
Il y avait "Singin' in the rain",
elle était là. Et je faisais ça.
Et manbelle,
ça ne la dérangeait pas du tout.
Elle rigolait,
alors qu'elle aurait pu me dire :
.."Tu caches l'écran,
tu peux te pousser un peu ?"
-Elle préférait nettement
te voir faire des roues...
-On était toutes les deux,
j'avais 4 ou 5 ans.
C'était la fête.
Tu as des photos ?
Moi, j'ai Manbelle, là.
La fameuse grand-mère.
-Manbelle, la voici.
Un exemple pour Julie.
Issue d'une famille de comédiens,
elle aussi finit..
..par monter sur les planches.
Elle rencontre son mari. Avec lui,
..elle fonde une grande famille.
Elle aura 11 enfants qui lui..
..donneront 33 petits-enfants.
Pour sa petite-fille..
..Julie, Manbelle restera
à jamais une femme hors du commun.
-Manbelle... Ben oui.
Manbelle, elle était...
C'était marrant, parce que...
C'était paradoxale.
A la fin de sa vie, elle a été
un peu handicapée physiquement,
..mais pas mentalement.
Et toujours cet entrain.
Moi, je l'ai toujours trouvée...
-Ce qui était extraordinaire
chez elle,
..c'est malgré tout,
malgré la souffrance,
..elle a toujours été
un moteur incroyable pour tout.
-Même pour l'argent,
alors qu'elle n'en avait pas.
Si t'étais dans la merde, elle
se démerdait pour trouver du fric.
Dans la tendresse,
dans l'écoute.
-Devenue comédienne à succès,
Julie éprouve..
..une éternelle reconnaissance
envers Manbelle. Sa grand-mère..
..l'a toujours encouragée..
..à aller au bout de ses rêves.
-C'était une grande passionnée.
Elle a donné la liberté..
..d'être et de faire ce que
tu veux, car ça sera bon pour toi.
-Très jeune, Julie a voulu faire
de la danse et du théâtre.
Cela a commencé en vacances
quand elle..
..se produisait avec ses cousins
devant sa grand-mère.
-L'été, on faisait des..
..spectacles.
On conviait tout le monde.
On faisait des entractes
avec pop-corn.
-Les parents étaient en bas,
..et ça faisait comme
un escalier monumental.
-Manbelle, elle adorait.
A la rigueur,
elle devait s'asseoir la première.
-C'était son régal,
c'était sa vie.
De les voir tous,
..comme ça, aussi à l'aise
dans le spectacle.
Et aussi dégantés,
c'était son bonheur.
Tant qu'on riait,
c'était bon.
-De ses premiers pas sur la scène
improvisée de la maison familiale,
..jusqu'à ses succès sur
les planches de théâtre parisien,
..Manbelle a toujours été..
..la confidente et
la conseillère de Julie.
-Quand j'étais jeune,
..elle voyait que je partais vite.
Je commençais à voyager partout,
j'avais 18 ans,
..je dansais. Et elle me disait :
"Te fatigues pas trop."
Et moi, je lui ai dit :
"T'inquiète, Manbelle !"
Et maintenant, des fois,
je suis là : "Manbelle,
"..j'en peux plus."
Elle avait raison.
Il y a quelque chose
qui pourrait me faire chialer..
..et que je viens de réaliser,
..je crois qu'elle ne m'a
jamais vu jouer dans un film.
-Non, jamais.
C'est sûr, même.
-Grâce à Manbelle, en tous cas,
dans la famille de Julie Ferrier,
..on est artistes reconnus
de génération en génération.
-Au revoir, mon Lolo !
Et merci !
-Mais il n'y a pas que
les grands-mères d'artistes..
..qui transmettent..
..leur vocation
à leurs petits-enfants.
Dans le sud de la France,
..sur les bords
de l'étang de Berre.
[*"En équilibre", de Chimène Badi.]
Cette grand-mère de 58 ans,
c'est Martine.
Elle adore chanter, en voiture,
chez elle, ou sur scène,
..mais sa vraie passion,
c'est sa petite-fille.
-Je vais chercher..
..ma petite-fille à l'école,
comme tous les vendredis.
En plus,
..c'est les vacances.
Je ne peux pas imaginer
ma vie sans mes petits-enfants.
Je ne pourrais pas partir
habiter à l'autre bout du monde.
-Martine à 2 petites-filles.
Mais avec l'aînée, Adeline,
..elle a développé
une relation fusionnelle.
-La voilà.
-C'est les vacances !
-Bonjour, ma poule. Ca va ?
-Adeline, la voilà.
A 10 ans, elle est en CM2.
Elle est ravie..
..que sa grand-mère vienne
la chercher, car elle partage..
..avec elle la même passion
pour la chanson.
*-Je suis en équilibre.
-Ce qu'elle préfère,
..c'est chanter..
..en duo avec elle.
*-Je ne regarde plus en bas.
*Tout est si loin déjà.
-Chaque vendredi soir,
en arrivant chez Martine,
..c'est le même rituel.
-On y va, Adeline.
Il est 17h40.
On va répéter. T'es prête ?
-Chaque semaine, elle répète,
car elles se produisent..
..souvent en spectacle
dans leur région. Dans 3 jours,
..elles devront assurer un show
dans une maison de retraite.
-"Attention,
mesdames et messieurs."
Puis, on chante "La java bleue".
-Je ne la connais pas.
-Je la ferai.
-Comme des pros,
elles choisissent leur répertoire.
-On commence par "Amstrong",
je ne l'ai pas fait depuis un bail.
*-AMSTRONG,
*..JE NE SUIS PAS NOIR.
*-Je suis blanc de peau.
*Quand on veut chanter l'espoir.
*Quel manque de pot !
-Tu vois, tu t'en souviens.
-Comment tu veux que je l'oublie ?
-Quel âge t'avais quand..
..tu la chantais pour la 1re fois ?
-J'avais 3 ans, c'était..
..au repas de famille.
-Voilà.
-Depuis, la petite Adeline
n'a plus lâché le micro,
..toujours en compagnie
de sa grand-mère.
*-L'AMERIQUE,
*..SI C'EST UN REVE...
-Pour Martine, c'est..
..son rêve d'enfant qui se réalise
à travers sa petite-fille.
Elle a toujours voulu chanter,
mais c'est à 50 ans qu'elle ose..
..se lancer.
-Adeline a attrapé le virus.
C'est pas que je veux qu'elle fasse
ça car je n'ai pas pu le faire,
..mais elle partage
la passion que j'avais, enfant.
Et elle peut le faire.
-En l'emmenant avec elle,
..Martine lui offre ses premiers
pas dans le monde du spectacle.
*-L'AMERIQUE, L'AMERIQUE.
*SI C'EST UN REVE,
JE LE SAURAIS.
-On s'est un peu trompées,
ce n'est pas grave.
-Le duo n'est pas prêt. Cela fait
des mois qu'elles n'ont pas donné..
..de spectacle. Elles ont 2 jours
pour revoir leur répertoire.
Mélange de style
et de génération.
-J'aime tout ce qui est variété
française. Je chante des années 30,
..que des chansons de 2010.
-Mes copines
disent que ça fait bizarre..
..qu'à mon âge..
..je connaisse par coeur
Claude François, les années 30...
-Pour Adeline et sa grand-mère,
..chanter c'est avant tout
l'occasion de partager.
C'est parti pour Grégoire,
..l'une des révélations
du moment.
Entre temps, Isabelle..
..est arrivée. Elle vient
chercher sa fille Adeline.
Mais quand elles sont lancées,
..personne ne peut les arrêter.
*-ALLEZ, VENEZ.
*ET ENTREZ DANS LA DANSE.
-On applaudit pas ?
[Isabelle applaudit.]
-J'applaudis toujours.
-Ecoute-moi.
Samedi... Il faut qu'on
se fasse un planning de ministre.
-Le jour qu'il vienne, Martine
et Adeline devront enchaîner..
..les répétitions pour être prêtes
et les séances de shopping..
..pour trouver
leurs tenues de scène.
-A demain.
Au revoir, ma poule.
-Une préparation
que Martine va devoir concilier..
..avec ses horaires de travail.
Mais parfois, la passion
de l'art permet aux grands-mères..
..et à leurs petits-enfants
de s'établir.
-Là, c'est une cape.
Quand on a froid..
..et quand on a un super héros,
on a une cape.
-Séance de maquillage,
..cape de super héros,
..bienvenue dans le monde de Super
Mamika, un univers fantasque..
..créer par Sacha, photographe.
Il a fait de Frederika,
..sa grand-mère..
..d'origine hongroise,
..son modèle favori.
-Elle est très professionnelle.
-Comment ?
-Très professionnelle.
Sauf quand tu bouges au maquillage.
Elle pose,
..elle est patiente,
elle propose des choses,
..elle comprend tout de suite
ce qu'il faut faire.
Elle arrive à avoir des degrés.
-Je ne vais pas rentrer
dans mes chaussures.
-Elles sont très larges.
-Cette aventure
a commencé il y a..
..6 ans.
Ces photos, d'abord publiées
sur Internet, remportent..
..un tel succès..
..qu'un livre est édité.
Mais tous n'auraient..
..pas pu arriver sans
cette étonnante relation.
-Ca me..
..semble difficile de ne pas
être complice de cette dame.
C'est un personnage..
..exceptionnel. C'est pour cela
que je fais cet expo et ce livre.
Je voulais que plein de gens savent
à quel point elle est incroyable.
Ce n'est pas une étoile,
c'est comme un masque.
-Entre Sacha et sa grand-mère,
beaucoup..
..de tendresse, et le même sens
de l'humour, parfois un peu décalé.
-Cette petite tête,
..on dirait une fleur !
-On dirait une barbe !
-On dirait une fleur !
-Vous avez souvent de tel propos ?
-Oui, on est capables.
De toute façon, c'est...
On ne fait pas des chats
avec des chiens.
Je suis un descendant direct
de cette dame.
Donc, parfois ça donne
des conversations un peu...
Chez nous, on dit "meshugge".
"Meshugge", c'est du yiddish,
..ça veut dire un peu fou.
-Un peu gâteux.
-Non,
..pas gâteux.
-Maintenant, c'est lui qui me dit..
..ce que signifie "meshugge".
Il sait tout mieux, d'ailleurs.
-On dit "Dieux sait tout,
mamie sait tout mieux."
C'est vrai ou pas ?
-Evidemment.
-Pourquoi vous vous maquillez ?
-Pour faire plaisir à Sacha.
Je suis comme toutes les
grands-mères, gâteuse devant..
..le petit-fils.
Sacha, reviens vite !
Tu ne vas pas me reconnaître !
-Bien ! Ah oui !
Dark Mamika !
On va commencer
faire des photos.
-On y va ?
J'ai le temps de rester.
-Frederika transformée
en super..
..Mamika, la séance peut commencer.
L'occasion pour..
..la grand-mère et son petit-fils
de partager..
..des moments de complicité.
-Tu as pris de la tête, non ?
C'est parti. L'histoire,
..c'est que tu regardes ici,
comme ça.
C'est ça... Très sympa !
-Mamika fait tout
pour plaire à Sacha.
-Fais-moi un vrai sourire.
Oui ! A moi, à moi !
-Mais c'est parfois fatiguant
quand on à 92 ans.
-On arrête.
C'était dur ?
Parfois, je vais trop loin.
En même temps, d'être là
tous les jours à s'en occuper,
..ça maintient en vie.
-Si Sacha..
..le photographe prend parfois
le pas sur Sacha le petit-fils,
..c'est parce que
leur aventure artistique..
..est devenue..
..une chose sérieuse. Les photos
de Mamika sont souvent publiées..
..dans les magazines..
..et s'exposent
dans des galeries d'art.
Nous sommes dans
le 5e arr. de Paris. Ce matin,
..Mamika se rend dans cette
exposition qui lui ait consacrée..
..et Sacha fait le guide.
-C'est beau, hein ?
C'est laquelle ta préférée ?
Moi, j'hésite.
J'adore..
..celle-là.
-C'était très dur pour moi
de faire cette photo.
-Pourquoi ?
-C'est très dur de voler comme ça.
Pourquoi j'accepte ?
Peut-être parce que..
..ça m'amuse.
-Et c'est ce plaisir partagé
qui nourrit..
..l'amour que porte Sacha
à sa grand-mère.
Mais avant tout,
..elle est un modèle pour lui.
-Avant d'être un modèle de photo,
pour moi, elle a toujours été..
..un modèle dans la vie
à presque tous les points de vue.
-C'est magnifique..
..ce que tu as dit.
-Quoi qu'il arrive,
..elle est là, je la garde,
il y en aura pas d'autres.
Moi, je prends tout...
-Ta grand-mère est à toi ?
-Oui, à moi.
-Mamika n'est pas prête
de quitter le haut de l'affiche.
Le public a craqué pour
cette incroyable grand-mère.
Aurélie, la galeriste,
a même proposé..
..une nouvelle exposition
dans quelques mois.
-Les gens adorent et ça parle
à toutes les générations.
Si le rendu est aussi réussi
et parle autant au public,
..c'est aussi parce que..
..la force de ces photos,
vient de la force du lien..
..entre Sacha et Mamika.
-Si Sacha est fasciné
par sa grand-mère,
..c'est aussi parce
qu'elle a eu..
..une vie incroyable.
Juive Hongroise, elle fuit
le communisme, puis le nazisme,
..avec sa famille..
..et 11 autres personnes.
Elle se réfugie..
..en France où elle devient
styliste, jusqu'à..
..ses 80 ans. C'est alors
que Sacha en fait sa muse.
-On a toujours fait des choses
ensemble depuis que je suis petit.
Tout ce qu'on fait là,
rien n'a été réfléchi.
On a surtout fait ça
pour être ensemble.
-Quand j'avais votre âge,
..le mot qui m'a donné
la chair de poule,
..c'était le mot "trop tard".
C'était un horrible mot.
Parce que si c'est trop tard,
..on a raté.
-On a raté quelque chose.
-Avec ses photos,
Sacha n'a pas seulement..
..occupé sa retraite,
il lui a offert une 2e vie.
Une vie où..
..elle est devenue
un vrai personnage..
..avec un public qui l'aime.
De quoi laisser longtemps une trace.
-Je voulais rendre ma grand-mère
immortelle, c'est ça la phrase.
Et ça fait des années
que je me dit :
.."S'il elle disparaît,
ça va être terrible."
Et je voulais
que cette dame-là, elle,
..qu'elle reste là pour toujours.
Les livres, même si ça se détruit,
..ça reste une trace indélébile.
Et même le jour
où elle aura disparu,
..beaucoup de gens l'auront vu et
auront leur possession des livres.
Et ma grand-mère sera toujours là.
-Tu ne m'as jamais dit ça.
Ca me fait plaisir, mais ça
me fait, quelque part, soucieux,
..car je vais mourir bientôt...
-Elle dit ça depuis 10 ans.
-Je suis très vieille.
Alors,
il va subir ma perte bientôt.
Mais c'est normal, c'est normal.
C'est la norme des choses.
Et j'aimerais qu'il se marie.
-Pour Frédérika,
la grand-mère de Sacha,
..l'important a toujours été
de transmettre la vie.
A l'aéroport de Roissy,
..un petit matin d'hiver.
Monique..
..est une jeune retraitée.
Avec son mari Vincent,
..elle s'est levée tôt..
..pour accueillir
un passager venu du Congo.
-Brazzaville, "posé"...
Quelle porte ?
-A 62 ans, Monique n'est pas
une grand-mère comme les autres.
Malgré ses 8 petits-enfants,
elle a décidé de s'occuper..
..d'un enfant malade pour
lui donner une chance de survie.
-On attend..
..un petit..
..garçon..
..qui arrive du Congo.
Je me suis toujours dit si..
..un de mes enfants avait
été malade, qu'une famille..
..puisse aider à ce qu'il soit
sauvé, c'est fabuleux.
-Cet enfant est confié
à ce couple par l'association..
..La Chaîne de l'Espoir.
Agé de 4 ans, le petit Eric..
..est atteint d'une malformation
cardiaque. Il sera opéré à Paris..
..dans 10 jours.
En attendant, Monique prendra
soin de son coeur malade.
-On n'a pas de poussette.
-Sinon,
on le portera.
-C'est quand même
des opérations à risque.
On sait qu'il y a..
..des possibilités..
..que ça ne se passe
pas bien.
-L'enfant pourrait
ne pas survivre..
..à cette opération.
Une éventualité que Monique..
..refuse d'envisager.
Mais pour l'instant,
..sa seule préoccupation,
..c'est de réussir
sa rencontre avec Eric.
-On a une photo.
C'est un beau..
..petit garçon. On va..
..le découvrir,
..sans oublier
nos petits-enfants.
-Dernière minute d'attente,
et les portes s'ouvrent.
-Voilà... Coucou !
Il a l'air..
..tout tristounet.
-Assis sur son chariot,
..le petit garçon
à l'air perdu.
-Bonjour.
Bonjour, Eric.
Tu as l'air d'avoir peur.
-Ce sont des bénévoles
de La Chaîne de l'Espoir..
..qui ont conduit Eric
de sa famille au Congo..
..à sa famille d'accueil française.
-Il a dormi tout le temps,
il n'a rien mangé.
Juste une gorgée de chocolat...
-Même si Eric parle français,
il reste muet.
Pour venir en France, il a quitté
ses parents et son village. Ici,
..tout lui est inconnu.
Mais Monique a tout prévu.
-On a apporté une écharpe,
..un bonnet.
Il a des affaires ?
-Ca c'est à lui.
-Pour faire connaissance,
rien ne vaut un bisou.
-On se fait un bisou ?
Tu me fais un bisou
ou je t'en fais ?
C'est toi ?
Tu vas être bien,
tu vas voir.
-Tu as une superbe voiture,
en plus.
-Un baiser,
un doigt qu'on serre,
..le premier contact..
..est établi.
A cause de son coeur malade,
..c'est sur le chariot
à bagage qu'Eric part avec..
..sa famille d'accueil.
Monique sait que pour
un petit garçon de son âge,
..c'est une terrible épreuve.
Alors elle multiplie les paroles..
..et les gestes d'infection.
-On est..
..à Paris.
Premier moment.
Alors on se demande un peu
ce qu'il y a dans sa tête,
..tout ce à quoi il pense.
Il n'a pas l'air..
..trop affolé,
mais il a besoin..
..d'attention..
..et de caresse.
-Malgré leurs petites attentions,
Eric est complètement déboussolé.
-Regarde ça...
Avec un petit pompon...
Tu vas être beau...
Oh, dis donc !
T'as plus froid.
Tu veux une petite écharpe aussi ?
Oh, mon petit bonhomme...
T'es enrhumé
ou un peu triste ?
Hein ?
Voilà...
On va faire
un gros câlin en voiture.
On va aller à la maison.
-Monique sent monter
la crise de larme.
Elle va tout faire
pour le réconforter.
-Je vais me mettre
à côté de toi.
Tu vas t'installer là.
Voilà, mon petit bonhomme.
On va mettre la ceinture...
On va ouvrir un peu ça.
Tu vas être bien.
Je me suis mise à l'arrière,
..car c'est important..
..qu'on fasse connaissance
comme ça,
..il à l'air un peu perdu..
..et tout triste.
Il a sommeil,
il va s'endormir.
T'aimes téléphoner ?
Tout à l'heure,
on téléphonera à maman.
Comment s'appelle..
..maman ?
Comment elle s'appelle ?
-Maman Parfaite.
-Comment ?
-"Maman Parfaite"...
-"Maman Parfaite", voilà
les seuls mots qu'Eric prononcera..
..dans la voiture.
-Regarde où tu vas habiter
un peu...
Il à l'air un peu inquiet,
quand même.
-Nous sommes à Fresnes,
dans le Val-de-Marne.
Le couple habite..
..dans ce pavillon.
-Eric, tu as vu la neige ?
Ca fait froid !
Ca fait froid...
-Mais à peine la porte franchie,
..ce que prévoyait Monique, arrive,
Eric éclate en sanglot.
[...]
-Maman !
Maman !
-Maman pense à toi,
tu sais.
Ecoute bien...
C'est pour que tu sois soigné
que tu es là.
Tu le sais,
maman t'as expliqué.
-Maman !
-Elle t'as expliqué, maman.
-Monique à beau le câliner,
nul ne peut..
..remplacer "Maman Parfaite".
-Le voyage t'as fatigué.
-Pour détourner sa peine,
..Monique lui propose
un petit-déjeuner.
-Viens là.
Il y a ce que tu veux,
tu choisis.
-Non.
-T'en veux pas ?
On va le laisser
s'il ne veut pas manger.
Tu ne veux pas manger là ?
-Viens voir,
ça devrait te plaire.
-Mais rien n'y fait.
Exténué et déboussolé, il va
se réfugier sur le tapis du salon.
-T'es bien, là ?
T'es bien ?
Tu viens tout à l'heure ?
On te laisse un peu.
On va le laisser un peu.
Il est tout petit.
"Savoir ce qu'il va m'arriver,
où je suis, suis-je abandonné..."
C'est terrible.
Maman Parfaite n'est pas là.
-Mais au-delà
de l'absence de maman,
..Eric est surtout fatigué
par sa maladie.
Monique et Vincent devront
faire très attention à son coeur.
Dans son cas,
un accident peut survenir..
..à tout moment.
-Il faut être prudent,
..avec la pathologie qu'ils ont.
C'est pas juste une colère,
..mais il respire très vite.
-Eric s'est calmé
et il s'est endormi.
Après une arrivée difficile,
Monique va..
..l'accompagner dans son périple
médical. Une intention de tous..
..les instants jusqu'à
son opération.
-On fait la fête ?
-OUI !
-Qui veut faire la fête ?
-MOI !
-Venez.
-Chez Jeanne,
l'ambiance est à la fête.
A 66 ans, elle adore
faire plaisir..
..à ses petits-enfants.
Comme touts les samedis,
..elle leur a concocté
un programme..
..festif.
Autour d'elle, Lana,
Nathanaël et Ethan.
Ce sont les enfants de Bachir.
Mais il y a aussi..
..Lydie, Sarah et Charlène,
..les enfants de Nathalie.
Et pour tous,
..Jeanne est au petit soin.
Six petits-enfants,
..un samedi ordinaire
pour cette grand-mère hors-norme.
Jeanne est à la tête
d'une famille nombreuse.
Jeanne a eu 11 enfants
qui lui ont..
..donné 18 petits-enfants.
Et son meilleur souvenir,
c'est quand elle a été enceinte..
..à 35 ans en même temps
que sa fille Nathalie.
-J'ai été mamie
en même temps que maman.
Je suis devenue maman
et mamie en même temps.
Ca, c'est trop beau.
-A 2 mois d'intervalle.
-Une aventure qui n'est pas pour
rien dans la relation privilégiée..
..qu'elle a su créer
avec ses petits-enfants.
-Lana, montre. Wouah !
-C'est une mamie parfaite.
Elle essaie toujours..
..de nous faire plaisir.
Elle nous ramène toujours..
..quelque chose.
Elle est toujours là
en cas de besoin.
-A chaque fois,
..on se presse d'aller chez elle,
car elle nous réserve toujours..
..une surprise.
-Surprise, fête, partage,
Jeanne assume..
..pleinement son rôle
de grand-mère.
Pour elle, le plus important,
c'est de transmettre.
-Ce que je peux leur transmettre,
c'est déjà un amour.
Un amour de mamie.
C'est très sérieux, ça.
Il faut leur montrer
qu'on les aime.
C'est tout ma vie...
C'est quelque chose de magique.
Voilà,
j'ai trouvé le mot, "magique".
Qui veut des bisous ?
-MOI !!!
-Si Jeanne s'occupe autant d'eux,
..c'est qu'elle n'a jamais connu
le bonheur de grandir en famille.
-J'ai été placée dans
un orphelinat pendant 11 ans.
Donc,
je n'ai pas connu mes parents.
Je suis une fille de la DDASS.
C'était une enfance chaotique.
Ma famille nombreuse est une
revanche sur ma vie que j'ai eue.
Une très belle revanche.
-Et beaucoup de reconnaissance
de la part de ses petits-enfants.
Ils lui écrivent des poèmes,
..des déclarations d'amour
qu'elle garde précieusement.
-"Ma petite mamie,
j'adore sa frimousse,
"..surtout quand elle sourit.
Elle est si jolie.
"Malgré l'âge, elle ne fait
qu'embellir son image."
-"Avec toi, la vie est belle.
Inoubliable,
"..une grand-mère comme toi,
aimable, belle et intelligente.
"Je t'aime, mamie."
-Merci.
...
-C'est des supers, supers
petits-enfants.
Et que je les aime tous.
-Des supers petits-enfants,
Jeanne..
..n'en a jamais..
..assez. Chez elle,
c'est un défilé permanent.
Voici Léo...
-Salut, Léo.
Fais-moi un bisou.
-Et Manon, accompagnés
de leur maman Angélique,
..la plus jeune
des enfants de Jeanne.
-Tu peux nous faire un café ?
-Quoi comme café ?
-Un cappuccino.
-OK.
-Quand on s'occupe autant
de ses petits-enfants,
..on a moins..
..de temps pour soi.
-Elle passe déjà trop de temps
avec nous. Elle donne son temps..
..à nous, aux enfants,
mais sa vie de femme,
..pour ce qui lui reste à vivre,
elle ne le fait pas. Elle ne sort..
..jamais danser, ne raconte pas
qu'elle a rencontré quelqu'un.
-La priorité de Jeanne
n'a jamais été son propre bonheur,
..mais celui de sa famille.
Cette nuit, il y a encore eu..
..une naissance.
Alors, Jeanne fonce à la maternité.
-On va se diriger..
..à l'hôpital..
..voir mon arrière-petit-fils..
..qui vient de naître
il y a un jour.
-Jeanne est déjà
arrière-grand-mère.
Elle a même
7 arrière-petits-enfants.
Mais à chaque
nouvelle naissance,
..elle est toujours aussi émue.
-J'ai le coeur qui palpite.
Je dois déjà l'embrasser,
faire un grand sourire.
C'est un être de plus
à choyer, à aimer,
..à dorloter.
-Et ce petit être, le voilà :
un garçon de 3 kg et demi..
..dans les bras de sa maman.
Il s'appelle Ilan.
Et voici l'heureux papa,
Brice, le petit-fils de Jeanne.
-Félicitations.
-Merci.
-Ca s'est bien passé ?
-Oui, ça va.
-Tu es contente, maintenant.
-Oui. Il est là, c'est l'essentiel.
-C'est ce qu'il y a..
..de plus vrai et de plus beau.
-Et vit enfin le moment
qu'attendais Jeanne depuis..
..son arrivée à la maternité.
-Bienvenue, Ilan.
-Jeanne tient son 8e
arrière-petit-fils dans ses bras.
-Ca, c'est l'avenir,
c'est la continuité de la famille.
-Jeanne n'a plus qu'un rêve :
..réunir toute sa famille autour
d'elle pour le soir de Noël.
Un réveillon
qu'elle veut inoubliable.
Mais pas facile
quand on est..
..aussi nombreux.
Nous retrouvons Martine
avec sa petite-fille Adeline.
Aujourd'hui, elles cherchent
des nouvelles tenues de scène..
...de leur spectacle.
Un moment de complicité
en perspective.
-Ca, ça te plaît ?
-Oui.
-Ca doit être ta taille.
-La grand-mère conseille
la petite-fille...
-Ca, ça brille,
..c'est joli.
-Mais chose plus rare,
..les rôles s'inversent.
-Viens voir, ça c'est joli.
-C'est au tour d'Adeline
de conseiller Martine.
Ca tombe bien,
..elles ont les mêmes goûts.
-Les paillettes...
-Les strass...
-Elle a des goûts modernes
ou pas modernes, mamie ?
-Modernes, plutôt.
-Tu prendrais laquelle,
..celle-ci ou celle-ci ?
-Celle-ci.
-Jetons un oeil.
Profite que mamie sois là.
-50 ans..
..sépare Martine et Adeline.
Pourtant, on dirait 2 copines..
..qui passent..
..en cabine d'essayage.
-J'essaie,
dans la mesure du possible,
..que ce soit
dans les mêmes tons.
Comme maintenant
elle s'habille en "small",
..je peux trouver
les mêmes robes.
Mais je ne veux pas
qu'on soit les soeurs jumelles,
.."Les demoiselles de Rochefort".
-Une fille qui s'habille comme
sa mère, c'est dur d'imaginer,
..alors qu'une petite-fille
qui s'habille comme sa mamie...
Mais Martine et Adeline
sont tellement complices..
..que pour elles
c'est naturel.
-J'aime faire les courses
avec elle.
On a une différence d'âge
assez importante.
Mais elle me donne
ses idées, ses goûts.
Mais on a des goûts similaires,
car tout ce qui brille, nous attire.
-Quand je serai plus grande,
..je récupérerai tous les vêtements
à paillette... Tout ça.
-Les robes de spectacle.
Si tu fais ma taille,
tu garderas tout.
Je te garderai tout.
D'accord ?
-Martine et Adeline
repartent donc avec..
..leurs robes à paillettes
pour leur spectacle de demain.
Mais à 58 ans,
Martine n'est pas seulement..
..une mamie folle
de sa petite-fille.
C'est aussi une femme.
-Bonsoir.
-Parfois, elle s'accorde
une soirée entres amis.
-Ca va ?
-La petite dit
"Maman, on se maquille,
"..et après on couche papa."
-Tu as couché papa ?
Il était malade ?
-Comme toujours,
avec Martine, il n'y a pas..
..de bonne soirée
sans chanson.
Mais ce soir,
..elle crée l'événement
en se lançant dans un duo.
-L'agitation, c'est que..
..ce charmant jeune homme
va chanter avec moi.
-Laurent répète avec elle
depuis quelques temps.
Certains insinuent contre eux.
Martine clarifie les choses.
-Là, je lui mets
une pression terrible !
J'aime bien mettre une pression
aux hommes !
Je vais vous dire pourquoi
il est avec moi.
Il vient..
..au moins une fois par semaine
chanter avec moi,
..et certains pensent..
..qu'il ne vient pas
que pour travailler.
Alors, je dis la vérité.
Etant donné que je vais faire
taire les mauvaises langues,
..je veux vous faire écouter
ce qu'on fait tous les deux.
On fait un essaie ?
-C'EST NOTRE JOUR..
..DE CHANCE,
L'ESPOIR, L'ARDEUR,
..PREND TOUT CE QU'IL TE FAUT,
MES BRAS, MON COEUR,
..MES EPAULES ET MON DOS.
JE VEUX TE VOIR TE VOIR
DES ETOILES DANS LES YEUX,
..JE VEUX NOUS VOIR
INSOUMIS ET HEUREUX.
ALLEZ, VENEZ,
ET ENTREZ DANS LA DANSE.
-Il faut avoir de l'énergie
quand on veut la suivre.
C'est une très bonne vivante.
Elle aime bien sortir,
s'amuser.
Elle vit sa vie
à 100 à l'heure.
-Et jusqu'au bout de la nuit.
Après le karaoké, elle met
l'ambiance sur la piste de danse..
..avec un autre..
..charmant jeune homme.
Et à 58 ans,
..Martine a une sacrée forme.
-Ca va,
je ne suis pas essoufflée.
Je peux encore danser
un moment.
Je dois les booster,
sinon les jeunes ne bougent pas.
J'essaie de les entraîner.
Parfois ça suit,
..mais ils fatiguent avant moi.
Je les fatigue, c'est vrai.
-Ce soir, Martine sera
la dernière à rentrer chez elle.
Mais pour elle,
pas de grâce matinée possible.
-Le lendemain matin,
nous la retrouvons dans ce foyer..
..pour personne handicapée.
-Tu as été sage,
tu le mérites les biscuits ?
-Martine est aide-soignante,
un travail..
..très prenant.
Ici, elle ne pense pas
à sa petite-fille.
Sans cesse accaparée par..
..les pensionnaires,
elle n'en a pas le temps.
-Tu mets ton pantalon...
On a tout préparé, hier.
Et ton pull-over.
Ne met pas devant derrière.
Oui, j'arrive.
Tu as tout ce qu'il faut.
Tu t'habilles.
Tu t'es rasé ce matin,
c'est bon.
-Pour Martine,
c'est un véritable marathon.
-Je peux rentrer ?
-Oui.
-Quant tu auras mis la cravate,
je te l'arrangerai.
Comme ça...
C'est fait.
Il est beau mon noeud.
Après je te l'ajusterai
quand tu auras ta chemise.
Ici, on est toujours..
..sollicités, ils ont toujours
des trucs à nous demander,
..un autre cravate, une douche...
On doit savoir répondre à tout,
même faire les noeuds de cravate.
Voilà.
-Martine gère tout en douceur.
Voilà pourquoi auprès des
résidents, elle fait l'unanimité.
-C'est une femme
que je la respecte bien,
..une éducatrice
que j'aime bien.
-Elle a un grand coeur ?
-Oui.
-Avoir un grand coeur, c'est
la nature profonde de Martine.
Aider les autres,
..un sacerdoce.
-En tant qu'aide-soignante,
j'avais 16 ans,
..et je ne me voyais pas
faire autre chose.
J'ai toujours aimé soigner
les gens, s'occuper des autres.
-Pourquoi ?
-Je ne peux pas expliquer.
Je ne me vois pas
derrière un bureau.
J'ai besoin du contact,
..de discuter,
..de rassurer les gens.
Je n'ai jamais voulu changer.
-Pour exercer ce métier..
..avec le sourire,
Martine a besoin de se ressourcer..
..en famille.
Elle file retrouver
sa petite-fille.
Ensemble,
..elles se mettent au fourneau
pour préparer le déjeuner.
-On fait revenir du beurre,
on met les échalotes dedans.
-Martine aime aussi..
..transmettre à sa petite-fille
des valeurs traditionnelles,
..comme la cuisine.
-Tu tiens toujours la casserole.
Souvent,
..le vendredi midi,
elle aime bien aider.
On mange toutes les deux.
-Mais aujourd'hui,
ils seront 7, dont Stéphane,
..le fils de Martine.
-Stéphane,
..on prend cette bouteille.
Il paraît
qu'il n'est pas bu.
-Stéphane,
c'est aussi le papa d'Adeline.
-Il n'est pas bon.
-Martine a à peine le temps
de terminer son plat...
-Bonjour !
-...que le reste de la famille
débarque.
-Salut, Michel.
-Voici Michel,
le gendre de Martine,
..Julie, sa fille,
..et Cassandra,
sa petite-fille.
Cassandra,
c'est la petite dernière.
Martine espère lui transmettre
elle aussi sa passion de la chanson.
-Les chaussures...
Elle va pouvoir monter sur scène.
-Les voilà au complet.
Une famille peu nombreuse,
mais très soudée et bonne vivante.
-Tu te mets en face de moi.
-Envoyez-nous les oies farcies !
Nous avons très faim !
-Attention Cassandra,
c'est brûlant.
-Pour Martine,
une famille unie, c'est important.
-Bon appétit.
-Bon ap'.
-Entourée de ceux..
..qu'elle aime, Martine a tout
pour être une mamie comblée.
Mais à peine assise,
l'émotion l'envahie.
-J'ai la chance d'avoir
2 enfants merveilleux...
Une belle fille,
un jeune homme...
Il manque une personne aujourd'hui,
je suis séparée.
-Il y a 2 ans,
après 30 ans de mariage,
..elle s'est séparée
de son mari.
Une rupture très douloureuse
dont Martine..
..à mis longtemps à se relever.
Sa résurrection, elle l'a doit..
..à sa petite-fille Adeline..
..qui l'a inscrite à Super Mamie.
Une révélation pour Martine,
car ce concours, elle l'a gagné.
-C'est moi qui
lui ai dit de s'inscrire.
Après elle s'est inscrite.
Un jour, j'étais en Corse,
..elle m'a appelée,
..elle m'a dit
qu'on était sélectionnées.
Sur le moment,
je n'ai pas compris.
Après, je m'en suis rappelée,
car ça faisait longtemps...
-Ca, c'est le départ
de mon aventure.
Ca, c'est un très beau cadeau,
un très bon souvenirs..
..que je garde pour
mes petites-filles, plus tard.
-De cette expérience,
..Martine garde un grand souvenir.
*-JE REVIENS A LA MAISON...
-Ce qu'elle n'a jamais oublié,
ce sont les mots d'encouragement..
..de sa petite-fille.
Une vraie déclaration d'amour.
*...
-Elle a dit :
"Si tu ne gagnes pas,
"..ce n'est pas grave,
car pour moi, tu es déjà..."
-"Tu es déjà
ma super mamie."
-Depuis cette élection,
Martine a changé de vie.
Elle est devenue..
..une star locale, fait la Une
des journaux, et passe à la radio.
Pour ses enfants,
c'est un retour des choses.
-On se dit,
comme elle disait tout à l'heure,
..qu'on peut avoir
une autre vie, construire..
..autre chose à 50 ans.
Elle fait plus pour elle
que pour les autres.
Elle a beaucoup donné
la première moitié de sa vie.
-On la voit à la télé, sur les
journaux, on l'entend à la radio.
Ca fait plaisir.
C'est un peu elle
qui est en haut de l'affiche,
..alors qu'elle était plutôt..
..derrière l'affiche.
-Et pour Martine,
tout ça ne serait pas arrivé..
..sans l'amour de ses proches.
-Sans toute cette troupe,
je n'existerais pas.
J'en ai assez
de pleurer comme ça.
-Martine a du mal à cacher
ses émotions. Pourtant demain,
..elle devra transmettre
son énergie et sa joie de vivre.
Avec Adeline,
sa petite-fille,
..cette Super Mamie sera sur
scène face au public pour chanter.
Chez Mamika aussi,
la famille est importante.
Le dimanche,
son petit-fils Sacha..
..a instauré un rituel.
La famille invite des amis
pour partager le repas.
-On est combien ?
-7.
-Six à table ?
-Non, 7...
Les garçons, on va à table ?
Je propose..
..que tu sois à la droite
de la grande maternelle.
-C'est un honneur.
-A sa gauche...
-Grosse pression.
-Aujourd'hui, Frederika
n'a plus assez d'énergie..
..pour cuisiner.
C'est Gabrielle, sa fille,
qui a pris la relève.
-Là, il y a de l'oignon,
du paprika...
Le paprika, et les poivrons.
-Pour Gabrielle,
..il a fallu composer..
..avec la relation fusionnelle,
entre son fils et sa mère.
-C'est très étonnant
à quel point il est proche d'elle.
J'ai l'impression que maman
l'a complètement séduit.
Il l'a mis sur un piédestal.
Et enfant, je lui ai dit :
"Maman a fait ceci, fait celà."
Il me répond : "Je ne veux rien
savoir. Ne me dit rien sur elle."
Fallait qu'elle soit parfaite.
C'est quelques fois...
C'était un peu agaçant
qui l'en fasse une icône.
Mais bon...
Ce n'est pas pareil
que si c'était...
C'est mon fils,
..donc on est plus attendris que
si c'était un frère et une soeur.
-Ici, les valeurs familiales ont
été plus fortes que les jalousies.
Et les trois générations
sont aujourd'hui très soudées.
Pour Sacha,
..Frederika a toujours été son
héroïne. Pour ses amis proches,
..elle est aussi devenue
la grand-mère de référence.
-Je n'ai pas connu
mes grands-parents.
Et du coup, ça me fait...
Ca me montre tout ce que
j'ai râté, tout le lien entre..
..une grand-mère et son petit-fils.
Et ça me fait ressentir..
..le manque, le rôle,
et la place d'une grand-mère.
-Qu'on les voit tout les deux,
un peu dans l'intimité,
..c'est un un vrai spectacle.
On pourrait écrire des sketchs...
C'est drôle.
-C'est une vraie grand-mère.
...
-Quelques jours plus tard,
nous nous rendons..
..à Lille, dans l'atelier de
Jef Aérosol, un grand spécialiste..
..de l'art de rue.
Pour diffuser plus largement..
..l'image de Mamika,
Sacha l'a sollicité..
..pour réaliser un pochoir
de sa "super" grand-mère.
Une technique..
..pouvant reproduire des images
en les peignant sur les murs..
..grâce à des bombes de peinture.
Mamika sur les murs..
..de toutes les villes,
..Jeff s'est facilement
laissé convaincre.
-Sa grand-mère,
..c'est notre grand-mère à tous.
C'est la grand-mère qu'on a eue,
..ou qu'on n'a pas eue,
ou qu'on aimerait avoir...
Ou qu'on aimerait
ne pas avoir.
-Pour réaliser son pochoir,
Jef s'est inspiré d'une photo..
..de Mamika.
-La découpe,
..c'est la partie
où on se vide le cerveau.
Et là,
c'est tout ce qui est gris,
..que j'ai commencé à découper.
Et la silhouette noire
sera faite ensuite.
-Jef ne connaissait ni Mamika
ni Sacha avant de se lancer.
Mais il a trouvé..
..des ressemblances avec..
..sa propre histoire.
-En découpant le portrait..
..de Mamika,
je pense à mes grands-mères.
C'est une image qui fait
remonter des souvenirs.
Et quand elles ont disparu,
on se dit :
.."J'ai peut-être pas assez
passer du temps avec elles..."
-C'est sur les murs de Paris
que Jef..
..va peindre Mamika.
Mais avant, il doit la rencontrer
pour la 1re fois. C'est Sacha..
..qui l'accueille..
..dans l'appartement
de sa célèbre grand-mère.
-Bonjour.
-Alex est mon assistant.
On s'est mis là...
-C'est le monsieur
dont je t'ai parlé.
-Bonjour.
-Votre nom ?
-Jef.
-Jef est peintre,
il va faire un portrait de toi.
-Et dès le 1er regard,
..Jef tombe lui aussi
sous le charme de Mamika.
-Au milieu des étoiles,
le maquillage de Mamika,
..il y a 2 petites éteincelles,
et je les retrouve là.
-Lui, je l'ai trouvé très gentil
et sympa, ce qu'il disait.
-Sacha est très heureux.
Avec ce nouveau projet, l'amour..
..qu'il porte à sa grand-mère
s'affichera..
..dans la rue.
-C'est un bonheur d'avoir..
..un type comme lui,
..qui puisse faire un portrait
de ma grand-mère qui est, pour moi,
..un des personnages
les plus importants au monde,
..qui s'endort, là.
-Pas du tout.
Seulement, je...
Tu en dis un peu trop.
Parce que "le personnage
le plus important au monde",
..c'est une énorme phrase.
J'attends ici.
-Au revoir, Mamika.
Je peux vous faire la bise ?
-Naturellement.
-C'est drôle,
quand c'est des filles,
..tu ne dis pas la même chose.
Je ne partage pas ma grand-mère.
Sauf en peinture.
...
-Les deux artistes ont jeté..
..leur dévolu dans un mur
du 16e arr. de Paris.
-Depuis 30 ans,
quand je peins un pochoir,
..que j'ai passé des heures
à le découper,
..au moment où je le retire,
il y a toujours le : "Ca marche !"
Ca marche tout le temps.
-Sacha lui prend des photos..
..du 1er pochoir de Mamika.
Son rêve :
que cette image se retrouve..
..sur les murs..
..de New York.
-Je commence à dessiner..
..les traits.
-30 mn plus tard,
Sacha découvre le résultat.
-Je trouve ça bien,
mais c'est au-delà..
..de ce que j'avais imaginé.
Maintenant, je vais devoir faire..
..en sorte que sur la photo
finale soit aussi beau que là.
-Ce pochoir, destiné..
..à se multiplier sur nos murs,
c'est la consécration..
..de la belle histoire
de Sacha et Mamika.
-Beaucoup de gens vont en parler,
voudront la rencontrer. C'est sympa.
C'est top.
Comment rendre
sa grand-mère immortelle ?
Merci, Jef.
Il n'y a rien d'autre à dire.
-Mamika restera à jamais
dans le coeur..
..de Sacha. Les grands-mères
marquent l'existence..
..de leurs petits-enfants,
car elles symbolisent l'amour.
Hôpital Necker, à Paris.
Nous retrouvons Monique,
..Vincent, et le petit Eric,
venu du Congo,
..à cause de sa
maladie du coeur. Monique..
..l'accompagne pour des examens
médicaux. Ils détermineront..
..si Eric est opérable ou pas.
-On a l'impression que..
..ce n'est pas le nôtre...
Ca va.
Mais c'est assez fatiguant,
éprouvant, nerveusement.
Un peu de stresse.
-Ca démarre par une prise de sang.
Mais pour Eric,
c'est déjà le drame.
[Eric cri.]
Bouleversée, Monique parvient
à se contenir devant lui.
-Ca y est.
Le médecin a fini.
...
-Cette prise de sang
a épuisé Eric qui s'est endormi.
-Bravo. C'est un grand garçon.
C'est génial.
-C'est difficile.
Il est si petit,
on ne peut pas lui expliquer.
Il a dû déjà connaître de telles
choses difficiles dans son pays.
Donc, c'est impressionnant.
C'est dur pour tout le monde.
A chaque fois, on a l'impression..
..que le coeur bat à toute vitesse
et qu'il est près d'un malaise.
-Monique est très préoccupée
par l'état de santé d'Eric.
-Merci beaucoup.
-AU REVOIR.
-Elle n'espère qu'une chose :
que l'enfant soit opérable.
Mais seul un cardiologue
peut le dire.
-Bonjour, docteur.
Il est très beau.
-Comment allez-vous ?
-Bien.
-Le professeur Sidi
est cardio-pédiatre.
Il fait partie de la Chaîne
de l'Espoir. Jugé inopérable..
..au Congo, l'association
a fait venir l'enfant ici..
..pour tenter de le sauver.
-Il vient du Congo. Il est suspect
d'un tronc artériel commun.
-La maladie d'Eric s'appelle
une "tétralogie de Fallot".
Plusieurs
malformations cardiaques..
..entraînent une circulation
anormale du sang.
Résultat : il est mal oxygéné.
Eric étouffe peu à peu.
-On le déshabille ?
-Il squatte, non ?
-Oui, il est souvent accroupi.
-Pourquoi est-il accroupi ?
Ca, c'est très important,
..car il coupe ses résistances,
il maintient sa pression artérielle.
Donc,
il rentre en malaise.
-Pour Eric,
Il est vital d'être opéré.
Une échographie du coeur dira..
..si c'est possible.
-Vous êtes prêts ?
-Oui.
-Prêts à entendre ?
[Signal sonore.]
...
-Plus ça va vite,
mieux c'est.
Ca se présente..
..très bien. Super.
-Eric pourra être sauvé,
et retrouver..
..une vie normale
si l'opération réussit.
-On va peut-être
le guérir définitivement.
Il sera inutile..
..de le surveiller, on ne va pas
mettre de matériel étranger,
..il n'aura pas de tube...
Il y a eu de la chance,
..il n'a pas abîmé ses poumons,
ni son coeur.
-Un vrai soulagement.
Tous les ans,
..une centaine d'enfants est sauvé
grâce à la Chaîne de l'espoir.
Et cela, grâce aux présences
de grands-mères, comme Monique.
-Si il était resté au Congo... ?
-Il serait mort.
Il n'aurait pas atteint 10 ans.
-Si il peut vivre maintenant,
c'est extraordinaire.
-Mais nous, on ne fait
que l'accueillir et le câliner.
Voilà, mon petit prince.
-Marcher, courir, jouer au ballon
comme n'importe quel petit garçon,
..Eric va enfin connaître
tout ces plaisirs.
Mais vu son état,
il faut agir vite.
Le chirurgien décide d'avancer
la date de l'opération.
-On voudrait l'opérer..
..assez vite.
C'est possible ?
D'accord. Mardi prochain.
Merci.
Merci ce que vous faites.
-Bonne journée. Merci.
-Merci beaucoup.
-Au revoir.
-Eric sera opéré..
..dans une semaine.
Alors d'ici là, repos complet.
-Allez Eric,
on va à la maison.
Une journée fatigante
et une soirée sereine.
-Quand Monique
reviendra à l'hôpital,
..Eric passera 6 h
sur la table d'opération.
6 h qui scelleront
définitivement son destin.
Nous sommes le 24 décembre.
Et ici,
..en Alsace,
Il n'y a pas de Noël sans neige.
Nous retrouvons Jeanne.
Cette année, elle veut..
..réunir toute sa famille
pour le réveillon.
Et l'événement
la rend particulièrement joyeuse.
-T'es beau, toi.
Si mes petits-enfants verraient ça,
qu'est-ce qu'ils s'amuseraient !
Ils regarderaient
ce que t'as dans ta hotte.
Que t'es beau !
-Quand on a 26 petits
et arrières-petits-enfants,
..on s'y prend longtemps
à l'avance. Aujourd'hui,
..il ne lui reste plus
que 2 cadeaux à faire.
-Si j'étais milliardaire,
ou millionnaire...
Avec plein de sous,
j'envoie tout mes enfants là.
"Servez-vous !"
-Jeanne n'est pas millionnaire.
Pour les deux cadeaux restants,
elle devra surveiller son budget.
-9, 90...
C'est pour Ethan...
Heu...
Oui, pour Ethan.
-Le cadeau d'Ethan rentre
dans le budget de 10E par enfant..
..qu'elle s'était fixée.
Mais l'une..
..de ses petites-filles a fait
une commande bien spécifique.
-C'est pas donné,
c'est 16 E quand même.
16 euros. Donc...
J'hésite.
-16E, c'est trop pour..
..son budget.
-Je vérifie dans mon portefeuille.
Est-ce que j'aurai ça,
pour lui offrir ça ?
Est-ce que j'aurai ça ?
15 euros. Oui,
je vais quand même lui offrir.
Ca, c'est pour moi.
Je lui fais plaisir, je... ?
Non, c'est ça.
-Une fois encore, Jeanne
a laissé parler son coeur..
..et a fait passer
ses petits-enfants avant elle.
Elle ne pourra pas s'acheter
ces tenues dont elle rêve.
-Je regarde tout.
J'y reste parfois 2h..
..juste pour regarder.
Là, c'est 11E.
Non, je reste sage.
Ca aussi c'est beau.
Je fais un sacrifice pour moi.
Et puis bon...
Et voilà.
-Un petit sacrifice
pour un grand bonheur.
Chez elle, Jeanne a déjà décoré
son appartement en l'honneur..
..de ses petits-enfants.
Elle doit..
..emballer les cadeaux. Et si
pour certains c'est une corvée,
..pour elle,
c'est que du plaisir.
-C'est une émotion très forte
quand je fais les paquets.
C'est quelque chose..
..que je n'ai jamais eu, petite.
J'aimerais être un enfant,
pour avoir tout ça.
Voilà.
On va les mettre
sous le sapin.
-L'ancienne enfant de la DDASS n'a
jamais connue de Noël en famille.
Alors, pour ses petits-enfants,
elle veut que tout soit parfait.
Mais pour Jeanne, Noël ce ne sont
pas que des cadeaux et de la joie,
..c'est aussi un douloureux rituel.
Sa vie..
..est parsemée de drame.
-Bonjour, monsieur-dame.
-Vous voulez quelque chose..
..pour aller près de l'extérieur.
-C'est pour mettre sur la tombe.
Aujourd'hui,
c'est l'anniversaire...
Je me suis mariée un 24 décembre.
-Helàs, son mari est décédé
il y a 28 ans.
-C'est trop beau !
C'est trop beau !
-Depuis, chaque 24 décembre,
..Jeanne dépose des fleurs
sur sa tombe.
Avec lui,
sont aussi enterrées..
..2 de ses filles
qu'elle a perdues en bas-âge.
-Bon anniversaire.
-Bizarrement, c'est ici
puise son énergie..
..et la force de se battre
au quotidien.
-Là, il faut donner
la joie pour les autres.
On ne pleure pas éternellement,
quand on a encore..
..des enfants
et des petits-enfants.
Maintenant, je suis contente.
Il a reçu son bouquet.
C'est bien.
-De retour chez elle,
Jeanne se fait belle..
..pour accueillir sa grande famille.
Tout le monde n'a pas pu venir,
..mais ils seront 17 à fêter Noël.
Elle leur a réservé une surprise.
-De les voir venir, déjà...
C'est un souffle d'amour
et de bonheur.
-Vous êtes impatiente, stressée ?
-Pas stressée...
Mais...
Je suis un peu impatiente,
je vais dire ça.
-20h, les premiers
convives arrivent.
En tête, Sabrina et Brice,
..les parents du nouveau né,
venus avec leurs autres enfants.
Viennent ensuite,
les filles de Jeanne.
Même si on attend encore du monde,
la fête commence.
-Venez, mes chéries.
Ah, ben voilà !
Tu as plus de force que moi.
-Jeanne porte un premier toast
avec ses trois filles :
..Jamila, Nathalie et Yamina.
-SANTE !
-Pour Jeanne,
c'est le début du marathon.
Après avoir trinqué, elle doit
déjà s'activer en cuisine.
Au menu, c'est couscous.
Quand on est nombreux,
c'est pratique.
Jeanne a presque déjà..
..tout préparé la veille.
-Ca, c'est la 1re étape.
Après, le couscous sera encore..
..dedans.
Si on n'est pas organisés,
c'est foutu.
C'est fermer la boutique, car après
on est désordonnés, stressés...
Quand on met
une chose après l'autre,
..tout fonctionne bien.
-Malgré ce stresse,
..Jeanne trouve toujours
le temps de s'occuper..
..de ses petits-enfants. Une danse
improvisée qui fait leur bonheur.
-Elle passe beaucoup de temps
juste pour faire quelque chose..
..de joli pour nous.
-Elle nous fait vivre
des moments fabuleux.
On veut toujours exprimer
ce qu'on a dans le coeur.
On lui dit : "T'es fabuleuse",
mais c'est encore plus fort.
-C'est l'heure de passer à table.
-A table !
-A table...
-D'abord,
les grands s'installent...
C'est bon,
vous êtes à table ?
C'est la cohue.
C'est les grandes familles.
-Au bout de 15mn,
..Jeanne va finalement réussir..
..asseoir sa grande famille.
-Là, il n'y a pas tout le monde.
Même si c'était le cas,
..il n'y aurait pas de place
dans l'appartement.
Le jour où elle n'est plus là,
j'espère qu'on pourra continuer..
..à avoir ce lien entre nous.
-C'est grâce à elle.
-Je pense.
C'est même plus que sûr.
Si elle n'était pas là, peut-être
qu'on prendrait moins de temps,
..et on ne serait pas
comme on est maintenant.
Heureusement qu'elle est là.
-Maintenant...
Une surprise.
Je vais me déguiser
en mère noël.
Et je vais distribuer
les cadeaux. On y va.
A tout à l'heure.
-C'était ça le cadeau surprise
de Jeanne.
Et au salon,
on ne se doute de rien.
[Harmonica.]
...
-Je ne savais pas
qu'elle jouait de l'harmonica.
Alors, je me demandais
d'où ça venait.
Et quand j'ai vu que c'était elle,
encore une fois, je suis étonnée.
J'aurais plutôt pensé
que c'était un fond sonore.
J'étais étonnée par le calme,
car depuis ce matin,
..c'est animé.
-VIVE LE VENT, VIVE LE VENT,
VIVE LE VENT D'HIVER.
BOULE DE NEIGE ET JOUR
DE NOEL, BONNE ANNEE GRAND-MERE.
JOYEUX NOEL...
-A toute la famille...
Enfants et petits-enfants.
-A la nombreuse famille
que l'on aime !
-La grande famille...
Et c'est pas fini.
Santé, prospérité...
-Et amour.
-Et un peu de sou.
Ben oui, quand même !
Et à mamie qui reste
longtemps vivante.
-OUAIS !
-Je suis très fière
d'avoir une belle famille.
Une grande famille.
La famille, c'est l'amour
au-delà de tout.
C'est quelque chose de très fort,
qui ne faut jamais détruire.
C'est une forteresse.
-Jeanne a offert..
..à sa famille
un réveillon inoubliable.
Un repas, des fous-rires,
des chansons : voilà comment..
..Jeanne se construit
une forteresse d'amour..
..pour tout ceux qui l'entourent.
Retour en région parisienne.
Il est 5h du matin.
C'est aujourd'hui que
le petit Eric se fait opérer.
Un jour difficile pour Monique..
..qui va traverser à ses côtés..
..la terrible épreuve
d'une opération à coeur ouvert.
-Ce matin, je suis stressée,
..inquiète.
Car c'est une grosse opération
qui dure autour de 6h.
Et c'est une opération de coeur,
et le coeur, c'est la vie.
Coucou Eric...
Tu sais qu'on va à l'hôpital,
ce matin.
D'accord ?
Ils vont réparer ton petit coeur...
Après, on rentre à la maison,
on se repose un peu,
..et tu repars au Congo.
Ils t'attendent au Congo.
Ca va être chouette.
Tu vas voir Maman Parfaite,
hein ?
[Eric dit une phrase.]
-T'es bien réveillé soudain.
-A l'aéroport, là-bas.
-Oui, ils viendront te chercher.
On va leur téléphoner avant.
On va prendre Winnie.
-Winnie est là.
-Il parle, il plaisante,
une métamorphose rendue possible..
..par toute l'attention
que lui porte Monique.
-Bisou à Mamoni.
-"Mamoni",
c'est ainsi que l'appelle..
..ses propres petits-enfants,
et qu'Eric l'appelle maintenant.
-Tu vas avec Papounet.
-Monique est devenue
la grand-mère de coeur..
..de ce petit garçon, comme
Vincent est devenu "Papounet".
-Papa Noël est là-bas.
-Il y en a partout
des lumières.
Qu'as-tu commandé..
..au père noël ?
-Des jouets.
-Des jouets. Regarde..
..les belles lumières...
-Mais cette année, pour Eric,
..le plus des cadeaux
sera sans doute la vie.
-Bonjour.
Un petit garçon doit être opéré.
Je le dépose et je ressors.
-Allez-y.
-Merci.
-Allez, on y va.
-On va te réparer,
on va te guérir.
-Tu viens dans mes bras,
Papounet va garer la voiture.
T'es lourd !
-Si tout va bien,
..dans quelques jours, Eric
pourra marcher. En attendant,
..c'est dans les bras de Monique
qu'il arrive à l'hôpital.
[Eric pleure.]
-Ne pleure pas.
Là, on ne fait pas
de misère.
-Eric a beau être en confiance
dans les bras de Monique,
..il garde un mauvais souvenir
de son premier passage à l'hôpital.
-Je veux pas qu'on me pique.
-Je ne te pique pas.
-On en a fait l'autre fois,
ça ne fait pas mal.
Ca ne pique pas
la petite lumière.
Ca ne pique pas, regarde.
-On va me soigner ici là.
-Mais oui, on va soigner là
ton petit coeur.
-Là, on va à la maison.
-Non, pas tout de suite.
Avant, le docteur
répare ton petit coeur.
La maison, c'est après.
Eric, tu t'assieds,
ou tu t'allonges ?
-Le petit garçon est enfin prêt
pour l'opération.
Il ne reste plus
qu'à l'endormir.
-Allonge-toi
pour regarder les dessins.
-Le problème, c'est qu'il va
refuser d'avaler son somnifère.
-Je vais te donner le petit
médicament avec le sucre.
Tu le prends tout seul
ou je te le donne ?
Il y a du sucre avec.
-Ben si, c'est bon.
-Pour t'aider un peu.
-Non.
-Ca va t'aider à t'endormir.
[Eric pleure.]
-Ca fait pas mal, ça.
-Il va falloir toute la gentillesse
et l'expérience de l'infirmière..
..pour qu'il avale enfin
son médicament.
-Maman !
-Je te donne le dernier,
après j'arrête.
-Allez.
-Voilà. Très bien.
-Parfait.
-Ca va vite l'endormir ?
-10mn,
..s'il se laisse aller.
-Hélas, ça ne va pas avoir
l'effet escompté.
-On va faire dodo.
-C'est parti en force !
Mon doigt comme ça,
..après ça me donne
le pouvoir.
-10mn plus tard, Eric
est plus réveillé que jamais.
-Ca lui a fait l'effet inverse.
-Comme parfois, chez les enfants,
..le somnifère s'est transformé
en excitant.
-Il fait la force.
Il m'a dit qu'il avait
une force extraordinaire.
-Vous pouvez le porter
ou nous le portons ?
-Je peux le porter.
Allez, on y va.
On prend Winnie.
-Au bout de ce couloir,
la salle d'opération,
..à laquelle ni Monique
ni son mari n'auront accès.
[Inaudible.]
-Fais un bisou
à Mamoni.
Mamoni vient te voir après,
..quand le docteur
aura réparé le petit coeur.
Avec Papounet,
on t'attend là.
-C'est là qu'il faut
se dire au revoir.
Pour ses grands-parents de coeur,
c'est un déchirement.
-Je croyais qu'on allait
jusqu'à la salle de l'opération.
On m'a dit :
"Faites-lui un bisou."
Il y a une espèce
de couloir immense.
On l'a vu s'éloigner.
Et effectivement,
ça sert un peu le coeur.
-Au bloc, l'équipe médicale
commence à préparer..
..l'enfant.
Pour Monique et Vincent,
..c'est le début d'une interminable
journée d'angoisse.
-On est angoissés,
..car on est responsables d'un
enfant, qui est tout fragile.
C'est vraiment très fort.
-Il y a ce risque que
le coeur ne démarre pas.
Donc,
même si tout se passe bien,
..l'inquiétude d'angoisse..
..de savoir si tout
ce qu'on a fait,
..ça va bien
se remettre en route.
-L'opération va durer 6 h.
Si tout va bien,
ce soir, Eric sera guéri.
Sur la côté d'Azur,
les enjeux sont différents.
Mais c'est aussi un grand jour
pour Martine et Adeline.
-Bonjour.
C'est maman qui t'as amené ?
-Oui.
-Dans quelques heures, Martine
et Adeline seront sur scène.
-Tu es prête, chérie ?
-Oui.
-Tu n'as rien oublié
dans ton sac ?
-Non.
-On va regarder tout ça.
Allez.
Tu mets ça dedans.
-En deux.
-Dessus ?
-Oui.
-On ne voit pas ton short.
-Ce n'est pas grave.
-Tu m'as dit que ça faisait
vieux de mettre les trucs dans...
C'était pas à la mode.
Moi, j'ai 2 tenues.
Et elle,
..elle en a 1, 2, 3,
..4, 5.
Elle est vraiment
dans le spectacle..
..jusqu'au bout.
-Tout est au point.
Il ne reste plus qu'à se maquiller.
C'est un rituel
avant chaque spectacle.
-Tu as des couleurs
pour les paupières ?
-C'est ici.
Tout est là-dedans.
Là, il y a des couleurs partout.
-La coquetterie,
une histoire de famille.
-Tu veux pas ce rose ?
-Non, je préfère le violet.
-Celui-là est très foncé.
Je ne veux pas que tu en mettes.
-Apprendre à Adeline
à se maquiller..
..semble naturel pour Martine.
Mais si elle lui prête son mascara,
..c'est uniquement pour le show.
-Dès qu'elle a commencé à faire
de la scène, on lui mettait..
..un peu de rose sur les joues,
des paillettes.
-Parfois,
..j'ai pris le maquillage à maman
et je me faisais n'importe quoi.
-Tu l'as bien mis.
Fais voir les yeux.
-Je l'ai mis les yeux ouverts.
-Les deux artistes doivent
transporter tout leur matériel,
..leurs costumes,
..et la sono.
-C'est la partie la moins...
plaisante.
Déjà, on dépense de l'énergie.
-Un travail à part entière,
..car il y a plus
de 40 kg de matériel à charger.
Et cela pour chaque concert.
Sur la route, Martine fait
ses dernières recommandations..
..avant le spectacle.
-Tu n'es pas obligée..
..de danser... Enfin, tu danseras
autour de moi, mais tu peux aller..
..auprès d'eux,
ils te verrons mieux.
-C'est dans cette maison de
retraite qu'elles vont se produire.
Les résidents sont installés.
Le spectacle est prévu
depuis des semaines.
La présence d'Adeline
suscite des curiosités.
-Vous allez danser ?
-Vous allez voir ce qu'elle
va faire. Et vous allez entendre.
-J'espère !
-Ce n'est pas le zénith,
mais pour Martine..
..et Adeline,
l'important n'est pas là.
-Ce que j'aime voir,
c'est les personnes qui sont..
..dans un fauteuil roulant.
Après quelques chansons,
..je commence à voir
un pied qui tape,
..une main qui tape sur la cuisse.
Et je vois même ces personnes..
..commencer à chanter.
Le but, c'est
de les rendre heureux.
Et je vois que je réussi à
faire ça. C'est le plus important.
-Vous lui a fait comprendre
à Adeline ?
-Oui, elle a compris.
Hein, chérie ?
On est là pour quoi quand on va
dans les maisons de retraites ?
-Pour leur faire plaisir.
-...les faire chanter, les faire
sourire, les rendre heureux.
-Je vais me changer.
-Oui, va te changer.
Vous la déranger, je suis désolée.
Mais il y a des choses à respecter.
-Elles n'ont que quelques minutes
pour revêtir..
..leurs habits.
Apparemment, leurs
nouvelles robes ont du succès.
-On m'a dit que j'étais belle,
je leur ai dit que c'était..
..la tenue des infirmières.
Ils ont fait "Wouah !".
-A quelques minutes de l'entrée
sur scène, Martine reste détendue.
De son côté,
Adeline ne tient plus en place.
-J'ai trop envie de chanter,
et de danser !
-Elle ne stressera plus,
..quand elle aura dépensé
toute cette énergie.
C'est un peu..
..sa manière à elle de...
C'est peut-être une sorte de trac,
..mais ça va aller quand
elle va partir avec son micro.
A la fin,
..elle sera plus calme.
-C'est le moment d'entrer en scène.
C'est parti..
..pour 2h de show.
*-Vous êtes..
*..un public dynamique. Je veux..
*..vous entendre chanter...
[*Elles chantent.]
*-ATTENTION, MESDAMES ET MESSIEURS,
DANS UN INSTANT ON VA COMMENCER.
-Martine et Adeline
enchaîneront les grands classiques.
Et progressivement,
la magie opère.
*-QUAND ON LA DANSE
DANS LES YEUX..
*..DANS LES YEUX.
*COMME ELLE AU MONDE..
*..IL N'Y EN A PAS DEUX.
C'EST LA JAVA BLEUE.
*...
-C'est un moment où on oublie,
on ne pense plus à nos malheurs.
On est un peu dans une fête.
Et la petite,
..elle vaut de l'or.
-Et pour le clou du spectacle,
une chanson chère..
..à Martine.
Celle avec laquelle
elle a été sacrée "Super mamie".
Costumes années 30,
un air qui replonge..
..tous les pensionnaires
dans leurs souvenirs de jeunesse.
Un beau succès..
..pour le duo.
-Je vois..
..cette bonne femme qui chante,
qui danse. Je suis en admiration.
-Pour Martine,
..une nouvelle occasion
d'être fière de sa petite-fille.
*...
-Je suis tellement fière
de faire ça avec ma petite-fille,
..que je trouve tout à fait
normal de la mettre en avant.
Elle est un peu la cerise
sur le gâteau aujourd'hui.
Je suis fière d'elle.
Merci, ma poule.
C'était très bien.
-Déjà d'autre spectacle
attend Martine et Adeline.
Mais le plus important,
pour elles,
..c'est d'avoir su créer,
au-delà de la scène,
..une rare complicité.
En région parisienne, c'est une
journée particulière pour Monique.
Pour la 1re fois, sont rassemblés
plusieurs de ses petits-enfants :
..Victor, 9 ans,
..Pablo, 6 ans,
Timéo, 3 ans,
..Paloma, 1 an...
Et bien sûr Eric.
Sorti de l'hôpital il y a quelques
jours, son coeur est guéri.
-Du parfum ?
-Oui.
Faut me faire
mon addition, alors.
-Aujourd'hui,
Monique peut jouer..
..avec Eric
qui regorge d'énergie.
Une victoire pour cette femme
qui a toujours pensé..
..qu'une grand-mère est là
pour transmettre la vie.
-On joue au match.
-C'est une vie qui leur ai
donné par une opération.
Et pour eux, c'est un peu
une nouvelle naissance.
Ils sont à nouveau
comme les autres.
-A voir ses petits-enfants
jouer ainsi avec Eric,
..on se dit qu'elle a réussi..
..à leur transmettre cette valeur.
-Timéo,
..tu aimes jouer avec Eric ?
-J'aime bien.
Parce qu'il est gentil.
-Je suis content pour lui..
..pour qu'il soit guéri
de sa maladie.
-Les grands-parents peuvent
aussi avoir ce rôle..
..de retransmettre
cette amour de la vie..
..et du don aux autres,
un peu quand même.
-On sait bien qu'il y a
des situations injustes,
..mais ça a un côté un peu..
..théorique, artificiel
pour les enfants. Mais là, non.
Ils ont sauvé un petit garçon
qui a été très malade, qui vient..
..d'un pays où on peut faire moins
de chose. C'est très parlant..
..de comprendre que le monde
est injuste d'une part,
..et qu'on peut faire des choses
pour faire essayer de le rendre..
..plus juste, et que
eux aussi ils participent.
-Les garçons,
on fait 2 groupes.
Timéo et Eric vont jouer,
et vous, vous m'aider à cuisiner.
-Transmettre les valeurs
de la vie à ses petits-enfants,
..Monique sait aussi..
..le faire aux travers
d'activité du quotidien.
La cuisine, par exemple.
Cette fois,
il y a des crêpes.
Ces liens ont permis
à Monique d'assumer son âge.
Depuis, sa vie a pris
un sens nouveau.
-Quand j'étais grand-mère..
..pour la 1re fois,
..ça m'a fait un petit choc, en me
disant : "On change de génération,
"..ça vieilli d'un coup."
Après, non. C'est génial.
Au contraire, c'est une façon
de se rajeunir un peu.
-Et avec l'arrivé d'Eric,
Monique a encore rajeuni.
-On va goûter les crêpes, Eric.
C'est la 1re fois
qu'il va en manger.
-Avec lui, les moindres gestes du
quotidien deviennent une aventure.
-On va essayer avec le sucre.
C'est bon, hein ? Hum ! C'est
aussi bon que les chouquettes.
Il me surprend de jour en jour.
Il marche, il court, il danse,
..il descend les escaliers seul.
Là, il est debout depuis ce matin.
-Demain, Monique va devoir
se séparer d'Eric.
Avant de se quitter,
..elle veut ajouter une photo
dans son album de famille.
-Eric,
..on va choisir deux photos
que tu veux mettre.
[Rires.]
On met celle-là ?
On a donné autant de temps,
..de tendresse,
qu'à nos petits-enfants.
On l'a considéré
comme un de nos petits-enfants,
..et on s'est occupés de lui..
..avec la même tendresse.
Oh, la joie !
Tout le monde est là.
-Ce soir, c'est la dernière nuit
qu'Eric passera chez Mamoni.
Demain, il rentre chez lui.
-Hop là !
-"Hop là !"
Au revoir Misty !
-Tu dis au revoir, Misty ?
Elle va être triste
que tu ne sois plus là.
C'est vrai
qu'elle était mignonne.
-Il n'y a pas que Misty
qui va être triste.
Eric va laisser un vide
dans cette maison.
-Tu as Winnie ?
Que vas-tu faire
en arrivant là-bas ?
-Je vais faire des dessins.
-Des dessins.
-Monique prépare doucement Eric..
..à retrouver son pays
et ses parents.
-Peut-être..
..que Maman Parfaite
a préparé un bon repas pour Eric.
Qu'a-t-elle préparé,
..à ton avis ?
-Du riz.
-Hum... C'est chic, hein ?
-Du riz de Mamoni.
-Non, ce sera le riz
de Maman Parfaite, ce soir.
Encore meilleur, hein ?
-Dans quelques heures,
..Eric va retrouver
sa "Maman Parfaite".
Et "Parfaite", c'est vraiment
le prénom de sa mère.
-Je vais arriver à la maison.
-Mais oui, mon chéri.
-Je vais lui dire :
"Maman, je suis guéri !"
-Ouais, génial !
-Arriver à l'aéroport.
C'est l'heure des adieux.
Eric et Monique
ont bien du mal à se quitter.
-Tu fais un bisou
à Papounet et à Mamoni ?
Tu me fais un bisou ?
1, 2, 3...
1, 2, 3.
-Bientôt, je vais venir.
-Oui, bientôt tu vas venir.
On va t'inviter. D'accord ?
-Oui.
-Et on va téléphoner, et on dira :
"Comment ça va Eric ?"
-"Tout va bien."
-Voilà !
Bisou à Mamoni ?
Bisou à Papounet ?
Et la main...
-On sert la main ?
Salut !
-Bon voyage, monsieur.
-Merci.
-Monique a les larmes aux yeux.
Ce petit bonhomme,
..pour qui elle s'est fait tant
de souci, elle ne le reverra pas..
..avant longtemps.
-Eric !
-On s'est attachés à lui.
C'est un petit..
..pincement au coeur.
C'est une belle aventure..
..qui se finit.
-En donnant à un enfant malade..
..un peu de temps et beaucoup
d'amour, cette héroïne..
..du quotidien a permis de sauver
une vie : celle d'Eric, 4 ans.
Entre le petit garçon
et la grand-mère est née..
..un lien que ni les kilomètres
ni le temps n'effaceront jamais.